mes chers collègues nous auditionnons
aujourd'hui Monsieur Bruno Lemer je
pense que d'autres collègues vont nous
rejoindre mais la session la séance
vient de se terminer et certains sont
probablement partis se
rafraîchir donc Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie des finance et de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique sur une actualité européenne
particulièrement importante pour notre
pays la réforme du pacte de stabilité et
de croissance merci monsieur le ministre
de vous être rendu disponible pour cette
audition par la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat à laquelle nous
avons aussi convié le président et le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances donc je salue la présence parmi
nous ainsi que le rapporteur spécial
Jean-Marie mon je ne sais pas s'il est
là monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances qui qui devrait nous rejoindre
je rappelle que le PACT de stabilité et
de croissance qui a été adopté en
1997 vise à garantir une coordination
des politiques budgétaires des
États-membres afin d'assurer le bon
fonctionnement de l'Union économique et
monétaire il reprend les critères de
mastrich ratio de 3 % du PIB pour le
déficit et 60 % du PIB pour la dette et
il comprend deux volets un volet
préventif visant à garantir des
politiques budgétaires saines à moyen
terme et un volet correctif avec une
procédure de déficit excessif pouvant
être déclenché lorsque les seuils de
déficit et de dett sont dépassés depuis
mars 2020 et le début de la crise covid
les règles du pacte de stabilité de
croissance sont suspendu en raison de
l'activité de la clause dérogatoire
initialement prévu pour fin 2022 la
désactivation de cette clause a été
repoussée à fin 2023 en réaction
conséquences économique de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie le retour aux
règles d'avant covid apparaît
aujourd'hui difficile d'une part leur
réintroduction sans flexibilité mettrait
en difficulté de nombreux États-membres
cont tenu des niveaux très dégradés de
leurs finances publiques je pense
naturellement en premier lieu à la
France d'autre part la prise de
conscience de l'importance des
investissements à réaliser en matière de
défense de transition numérique et
climatique rent inadapté le cadre actuel
une réforme s'impose donc mais quels
seraient les contours de ce nouveau
cadre cette question était la semaine
dernière à l'ordre du jour de notre
commission nos rapporteurs Florence
blatrix conta et Christine Lavarde nous
ont présenté une communication faisant
le point sur l'avancée des négociations
le jeudi 6 décembre le soir même
monsieur le ministre vous dignez avec
vos collègue ministre des Finances de
l'Union européenne dans l'espoir de vous
mettre d'accord et euh la négociation
qui a duré tard dans la nuit c'est
poursuivi le lendemain vous y avez
plaidé pour une flexibilité dans le
rythme de réduction des déficits pour
les États-membres faisant l'objet d'une
procédure de déficit excessif à
condition qu'ils investissent dans des
secteurs strat
ù mène des réformes structurelles
porteuses de croissance malgré des
avancées substantielles la négociation
n'a finalement pas abouti vous avez
indiqué à l'issue qu'un accord avait été
trouvé sur 95 % de la réforme quand
votre homologue allemand estimait pour
sa part que les propositions espagnoles
de compromis constituaient le début d'un
autre débat technique et pas à
conclusion le Conseil Ecofin semble prêt
à se réunir encore pour trouver un d'ici
Noël le temps presse en effet car les
nouvelles règles doivent être approuvées
par le Parlement européen avant sa
dissolution en avril les élections
européennes se tenant au mois de juin
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
présenter d'abord la position que vous
défendez au nom de la France dans ces
négociations puis nous exposer ce qui a
déjà été convenu avec nos partenaires et
nous donner des précision sur les 5 %
qui restent sur la table des
négociations je vous rappelle que vous
nous aviez précisé 95 % des des
discussions avaient abouti à un accord
ces 5 % c'est tout l'enjeu du dernier
kilomè c'est toujours le plus difficile
à conquérir donc nous serions curieux de
savoir dans quelle mesure les échanges
bilatéraux que vous avez avec votre
homologue allemand peuvent nourrir un
certain optimisme monsieur le ministre
je vous cède la parole puis nous
laisserons la parole au président de la
commission des finances et au rapporteur
général merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci de m'accueillir pour
cette audition sur les nouvelles règles
du pacte de stabilité et de croissance
ça ne fait pas la une de la presse mais
c'est probablement un des sujets les
plus stratégiques pour le pays pour les
années voir les décennies à venir je
voudrais partir de deux constats avant
de répondre aux questions du président
rppin
le premier constat c'est que les écarts
de dette et de situation budgétaire
entre les États-membres non'ont jamais
été aussi élevé depuis la crise du covid
et la crise inflationniste l'écart
maximal de niveau de dette publique
entre l'état le plus endetté la Grèce et
les États les moins endettés comme le
Luxembourg ou d'autres atteignent 150
points la Grèce un niveau de dette
publique de 166%
le Luxembourg un niveau de dette
publique de 25 % de sa richesse
nationale chacun mesure bien que dans ce
contexte là les règles anciennes qui ne
sont plus appliquées jusqu'à la fin 2023
comme vous l'avez rappelé sont obsolètes
le 60 % de dte publique a du sens quand
la marge est entre 40 et 70 % elle n'a
plus aucun sens lorsque la marge est
entre 25 et 160 ou 170 % de la richesse
nationale donc premier constat les
règles actuelles sont obsolètes deuxième
constat très important parce que le PACT
de stabilité et de croissance doit
servir un objectif politique s'il y a
bien un sujet qui me préoccupe
aujourd'hui c'est l'écart de croissance
et de productivité entre les États-Unis
et l'Europe nous sommes en train de
perdre la
partie les États-Unis ont aujourd'hui
2,5 % de croissance pour l'année
2023 la moyenne des États de la zone
euro c'est 0,6 %. c'est deux points de
croissance de
moins nous ne pouvons pas continuer
comme cela avec des États-Unis qui ont
une croissance forte qui crée beaucoup
d'emplois qui investissent qui innovent
qui récupère des pans entiers de
l'industrie européenne et l'Europe qui
elle resterait les bras croisés donc
nous Plon avec le président de la
République depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois pour que l'Europe fasse les
investissements nécess
sur la décarbonation sur l'innovation
sur la sécurité il y a urgence à le
faire il y a plusieurs façons de le
faire ça peut être des investissements
nationaux ça peut être des
investissements européens ça peut être
des facilités qui sont données mais je
le redis le pack de stabilité et de
croissance doit servir un objectif
politique et nous notre objectif
politique c'est une Europe puissante et
prospère pas une Europe en récession et
pas une Europe de l'
je voudrais également souligner un
impératif en début d'audition chacun
mesure bien les besoins d'investissement
massifs qui existent aujourd'hui en ce
début du 21e siècle les investissements
dans la décarbonation économique et dans
l'industrie verte ils sont
indispensables si nous voulons pas
laisser des P entiers de l'industrie là
encore aux États-Unis des
investissements dans la défense et j'ai
bien peur que ce qui se passe en Ukraine
se rappelle douloureusement à notre bon
souvenir et enfin des investissements
dans l'intelligence artificielle si nous
avons encore l'ambition qui est en tout
cas la mienne et celle de ma majorité
d'avoir une intelligence artificielle
générative européenne indépendante et là
aussi je vrais que chacun mesure le
moment où nous sommes soit demain nous
sommes clients de chat GPT de Google et
de Microsoft très bien nous ne serons
plus indépendants soit nous créons notre
propre intelligence artificielle
générative avec nos propres entreprises
mais ça va coûter beaucoup d'argent et
demander des investissements colossaux à
titre d'exemple président de Microsoft
que j'ai rencontré la semaine dernière
entend investir pour les années qui
viennent 100 milliards d'euros d'achat
de
microprocesseur aucun État européen et
même l'Union européenne dans son
ensemble n'atteint à elle seule le
montant de cette investissement d'une
seule entreprise privée
américaine dans ce contexte il est
évidemment
indispensable de revenir sur les
anciennes règles qui ont été définies il
y a plus de 25 ans si nous ne
redéfinissons pas ces règles nous
reviendrons au 1er janvier 2024 aux
règles anciennes qui sont je le redis
totalement obsolètes ce sera à la fois
une erreur économique car ces règles
sont procycliques et donc nous
entraînerit dans l'austérité
et ce serait en plus une faute politique
parce que cela marquerait l'impuissance
des États européens à se mettre d'accord
sur des éléments structurants de
l'avenir en commun il faut donc de
nouvelles règles qui doivent reposer à
notre sang sur trois principes nouvelles
règles qui doivent être définies pour le
prochain quart de siècle à minima ces
trois principes ce sont ceux pour
répondre à la question du président
Rapin que nous avons défendu avec
beaucoup de constance depuis plusieurs
mois au nom de la France
le premier principe c'est la
différenciation des trajectoires
budgétaires nationales c'est pas la même
chose de partir de 25 % de dett publi ou
de 160 % de dte publique c'est basique
mais c'est une réalité qu'il est bon de
rappeler donc nous voulons que sur la
base d'une évaluation de la dette et de
la soutenabilité de la dette j'y
reviendrai la fameuse DSA de
sustainability
analysis nous puissions définir des
trajectoires de réduction de la dette et
de réduction des déficits correspondant
à la situation particulière de chaque
État c'est ce qu'on appelle la
différenciation deuxème principe que
nous avons défendu celui de
l'appropriation c'est-à-dire que c'est
chaque État qui doit définir sa
trajectoire budgétaire
nationale c'est un point très important
ce que j'entends dire tout le temps
notamment de la part de certains partis
que on se fait dicter les règles par la
Commission européenne c'est totalement
faux au contraire ces nouvelles règles
reposeront sur les propositions des
États-membres enfin troisème principe
que nous avons défendu qui est
absolument fondamental et qui était au
cœur de notre nuit blanche de la semaine
dernière c'est la nécessité de prendre
en compte les investissements et les
réformes dans le bras préventif comme
dans le bras correctif le bras préventif
quand vous êtes sous les 3 % de déficit
et le bras correctif quand vous êtes
au-dessus des 3 % de déficit pourquoi
parce que nous voulons qu' dans tous les
cas de figure tous les États-membres
aient un intérêt à investir et à faire
des réformes de structure sans quoi une
fois encore nous serons le continent de
l'austérité au lieu d'être le continent
de la prospérité moi je veux que
l'Europe soit le continent de la
prospérité et certainement pas le
continent de l'austérité voilà la
position que nous avons défendu depuis
plusieurs mois à longueur de négociation
qui ont duré je le redis plus d'un an
maintenant qui m'ont amené à de
multiples rencontres avec mon homologue
allemand et qui me permett de vous dire
ce soir que nous sommes désormais tout
proche d'un
accord nous avons progressé sur chacun
des points que j'ai mentionné dans le
cadre du bras préventif c'est-à-dire
lorsque les États sont sous les 3 % de
déficit public l'accord est quasiment
complet accord sur la
différenciation une analyse de
soutenabilité de la dette une DSA sera
faite par chaque État et pour chaque
État membre elle tiendra compte de la
situation de chaque État ça croissance
potentielle sa démographie sa situation
de finances publi à partir de là un
système d'ajustement sera mise en place
pour mettre l'État sur une trajectoire
soutenable à moyen terme c'est-à-dire à
horizon de 10 ans cette différenciation
reposera sur un indicateur précis la
croissance des dépenses primaires hors
charge d'intérêt de la dette net des
mesures de prélèvement obligatoire qui
pourrai être décidé par les états donc
il y a bien un indicateur très clair
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en bon
français nous regarderons la croissance
des dépenses hors charge d'intérêt de la
dette les dépenses primaires dont nous
retirerons les mesures nouvelles qui
restent à la main des états c'est-à-dire
celles qui pent sur les impôts et les
taxes des prélèvement obligatoire par
ailleurs dans ce bras préventif il est
convenu conformément à la position
constante de la France qu'il y aura une
extension possible de redressement de la
dette de 4 à 7 ans si jamais un état
fait des investissements avec une liste
d'investissement précis notamment sur la
décarbonation ou fait des réformes de
structure donc ça nous semble un
dispositif particulièrement vertueux on
part de la situation de chaque État on
regarde comment définir sa trajectoire
de désendettement adapté à sa situation
personnelle situation des finances
publiques situation démographique
situation de croissance potentielle on
lui laisse évidemment toute marge de
manœuvre sur les impôts et sur les taxes
et si jamais il fait des mesures
structurelles où il prend des
investissements indispensables on lui
donne 3 années de plus pour réduire sa
dette enfin deuxième principe dans le
bras préventif l'appropriation je le
rappelle c'est l'État membre qui propose
lui-même son propre plan de
désendettement de moyen terme donc je ne
peux pas laisser dire que la Commission
impose quoi que ce soit simplement on
est dans un ensemble budgétaire commun
il y a des règles communes chacun doit
les respter mais chacun définit sa
méthode pour respecter ses règles
budgétaires et le nécessaire
désendettement toute la discussion qui a
eu lieu lors de l'écopin des 7 et 8
décembre 2023 qui a duré pour tout dire
toute la nuit a porté sur le bras
correctif c'est-à-dire lorsque le
déficit des états est supérieur à 3 %.
il est évident que l'intérêt direct de
la France était engagé puisque nous
sommes sous nous sommes au-dessus pardon
les 3 % de déficit et nous le serons
jusqu'en 2000 207 si on peut faire mieux
si la croissance é rendez-vous et que
les parlementaires dans leur très grande
sagesse proposent des économies
supplémentaire nous pouvons aller plus
vite nous serons très heureux d'aller
plus vite mais dans l'état de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nous passons sous les 3 % de déficit
public en 2027 donc nous sommes dans le
bras correctif dans la procédure pour
déficit excessif dans ce cas-là la règle
qui s'applique c'est une règle de Z0 ,5
points d'ajustement structurel par an
c'està-dire un ajustement qui tient
compte de la charge d'intérêt de la
dette c'est la règle qui a toujours été
définie et c'est une règle sur laquelle
l'immense majorité des États-membres ne
veut pas revenir en estimant que tout
assouplissement de cette règle poserait
une
difficulté le problème que
poseapplication stricte de cette règle
c'est le point sur lequel j'ai insisté
c'est qu'elle est procyclique et dans
une situation où vous avez tant d'États
qui sont en récession ou d'autres États
qui ont des niveau de croissance très
faibles et une croissance moyenne de
l'Union européenne qui est aussi faible
avoir une règle d'ajustement en bras
correctif aussi strict va conduire à
alimenter la récession et le
ralentissement de la croissance en
Europe c'est exactement ce que nous
avons connu pendant la période de la
crise financière avec des règles trop
strictes ét imposé à la Grèce et qui ont
finalement ralenti le redressement de la
grèe nous avons donc beaucoup négocié
notamment avec notre partenaire allemand
et nous sommes tombés d'accord avec mon
homologue allement Christian lner sur la
possibilité de déduire pendant ces 3 ans
2025 2026
2027 de l'augmentation de la charge de
l'intérêt de la dette les
investissements et les réformes qui
seraiit fait donc on regardera quelle
est la charge d'intérêt supplémentaire
de la dette sur cette période là et on
pourra en déduire les investissements et
les réformes ce qui est une incitation
évidemment à faire des investissements
dans la décarbonation et à faire des
réformes de structure et donc à
alimenter la croissance y compris quand
on est au-dessus des 3 % de déficit et
qu'on est dans le bras correctif je
salue d'ailleurs l'esprit d'ouverture
dont a fait preuve mon homologue
allemand ça n a permis de trouver un
compromis je pense que nous nous avons
été très clair sur le respect des règles
nous avons accepté je visis et revenir
un certain nombre de garde-fous et
l'Allemagne de son côté a accepté de
tenir compte de cette demande que je
crois justifiée et indispensable
d'inclure les investissements et les
réformes dans le bras correctif de notre
côté nous avons accepter que les
gardesfous soient rigoureux et sérieux
et je pense qu'il est indispensable que
les règles qui sont définis les
nouvelles règles fassent l'objet de
contrôle et de gardefou sérieux
contrairement aux anciennes règles qui
sont tellement strictes et avec des
gardes de fou tellement dur que
finalement elles ne sont jamais appliqué
depuis 25 ans ce qui n'est pas la
meilleure garantie de crédibilité de ces
règles premier gardefou premier
safegarde sur la dette l'obligation est
faite aux état de réduire d'un point la
dette en moyenne par an une fois que les
États sont sortis de la procédure pour
déficit excessif là aussi ça été une
longue négociation l'Allemagne préférant
un point de baisse de la dette
systématiquement chaque année et pendant
plusieurs semaines nous avons négocié un
point de baisse de dette en moyenne par
an ce qui me paraît bien préférable
parce qu'il faut tenir compte des aléas
conjoncturels il vaut parfois mieux
faire 0,8 une année 1 2 l'année suivante
et faire un en moyenne que d'être obligé
chaque année de faire systématiquement
un point de baisse de dette sur le
déficit le point d'accord sur lequel
nous sommes parvenus c'est 1,5 % de
déficit structur
comme objectif cible alors je rappelle
aussi pour éviter toute confusion que ce
n'est pas comme je l'ai lu longueur de
journée dans les journaux une division
par deux de l'objectif cible de l'actuel
Pact de stabilité dans le pacte de
stabilité actuel la cible est à
0,5 et le 3 % que tout le monde a en
tête est un plafon donc il faut comparer
ce qui est comparable nous passons d'un
objectif C de 0,5 à un objectif cible de
15 ce qui laisse un peu plus de marge de
manœuvre et le plafond est toujours à 3
parce que c'est le plafond à partir
duquel la dette et le niveau de dette
publique peut baisser dans un État
membre sur ce déficit l'objectif est
d'avoir 0,4 points par an d'ajustement
pour parvenir à cet objectif cible de
1.5 de déficit structurel avec là aussi
en bras préventif la possibilité d'
avoir un ajustement plus lent de 0,25
par an si un État fait des
investissements ou des réformes de
structure donc je pense que la vraie
victoire française dans cette discussion
a été d'obtenir que en bras correctif
comme en bras préventif il y ait
l'incitation à faire des investissements
et à faire des réformes de structure
comme la réforme des retraites ou la
réforme de l'assurance chômage enfin
dans ces nouvelles règles sur lesquelles
nous travaillons les sanctions sont plus
plus progressive moins procyclique elles
peuvent être révisées tous les 6 mois
elles sont donc plus crédibles que les
règes actuelles don je le redis elles
n'ont jamais été appliqué trois
conclusions pour
terminer d'abord nous n'avons pas
d'accord définitif nous avons
aujourd'hui un accord entre la France et
l'Allemagne qui était soutenu par
l'Italie et la présidence espagnole donc
c'est déjà une avancée majeure il reste
à convaincre les États du Nord les états
dit frugo les États baltes les Pays-Bas
la Finlande la Suède le Dannemark de
rejoindre cet accord il y aura donc un
nouvel Ecofin une nouvelle réunion des
ministres des Finances avant la trêve de
fin d'année pour finaliser cet accord et
je tiens vraiment à souligner l'état
d'esprit très coopératif dans lequel
nous avons travaillé avec l'Allemagne
avec l'Italie et avec la présence
espagnole et je salue le travail
remarquable qui a été fait notamment par
la présidente espagnole Nadia Calvino
qui est appelée à devenir président de
la Banque européenne
d'investissement le deuxième point que
je veux souligner après des règles qui
sont adaptées à la situation économique
c'est que ces règles sont aussi moins
brutales je donne juste l'état actuel du
droit aujourd'hui vous avez cette
fameuse règle des 12/0e quand votre
dette est supérieure au plafond de 60 %
de richesse nationale dans ce cas-là
vous êtes obligé de réduire le montant
de votre dette publ de l'écart à 60 % de
12/0e par an c'est cette fameuse règle
des 12/0e qui est à la fois absurde et
totalement hors de porté je prends
l'exemple de la France qui a un niveau
de dette publique de 110 % de son PIB il
y a donc entre la cible à 60 % et la
réalité de la dette un écart à la cible
de 50 points si on divise par 20 suivant
cette règle du 20e cela fait 2,5 points
de PIB d'ajustement de la dette par an
obligatoire suivant les règles actuelles
le point de PIB étant à 26 milliards
d'euros cela voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait que nous trouvions 67 milliards
d'euros d'économie par an autant vous
dire que c'est la récession garantie
pour toutes les années qui viennent donc
vous tuez la croissance vous tuez le
rétablissement des finances publiques et
vous tuez le pays tout court donc ces
règles n'ont plus aucun sens aujourd'hui
enfin dernier élément ce sont des règles
qui préservent les investissements et
les réformes je le redis je pense que
c'est le point clé que nous avons obtenu
après des mois de négociation ça me
paraît très important j'espère
maintenant et je vais me battre pour ça
que nous aurons d'ici la fin de l'année
un accord global non seulement entre
France Italie Espagne et Allemagne mais
également avec les 23 autres
États-membres pour que de nouvelles
règles s'appliquent qui soient à la fois
plus responsables et plus
efficace merci monsieur le ministre
avant de passer la parole au président
de la commission des finances juste de
de petites questions
qui peuvent avoir une réponse rapide je
je suis allé à à Berlin avec le le
président du Sénat et nous avons
rencontré le le ministre
Schmid on n' pas réussi à percevoir si
l'impact de la décision de la cour de
carlesrou avait été ressenti dans dans
dans la négociation qui a eu lieu vous
avez beaucoup parler de l'Allemagne donc
est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
qu'il y a un impact et que la
trajectoire allem en tout cas la
trajectoire politique puisse puisse
encore évoluer à ce sujet puis deuxème
point on pense que finalement l'organe
de de de surveillance restera bien sûr
la Commission on voit qu'on est sur des
échéances moyennes y y a-t-il une clause
de revoyure qui sera prévue imaginant
que à un certain moment on peut on peut
penser que que les les mesures pris
seraiit insoutenable ou deviendrait
deviendrait
compliqué alors ce premier point la
réponse est est oui je rappelle que la
décision de Cerou vise à requalifier
dans le budget allemand les fameux fonds
spéciaux à hauteur de 60 milliards
d'euros imaginez que je sois dans une
situation où faille que je requalifie 60
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
cela me compliquerait sacrément la tâche
il faut se faire aucune illusion sur les
conséquences de cette décision de la
Cour constitutionnelle de carlou ça
amène l'Allemagne avoir une position
plus dure sur les sujets de finances
publiques mais je le redis nous avons
construit une relation de confiance avec
Christian
Lidner et je pense que cela nous a aidé
à bâtir ce compromis qui respecte les
intérêts et les attentes du peuple
allemand et du peuple français sur la
clause revoyure il n'y a pas de clause
revoyure dans le texte mais je rappelle
qu'il y a deux points qui sont
importants c'est sur les sanctions elles
peuvent être visé tous les 6 mois et
enfin il y a bien entendu j'aurais dû le
dire une escape close c'est une
possibilité de suspendre l'application
des règles du pacte en cas de crise
comme celle du covid ou la crise
inflationniste que nous avons connu
merci c'était clair je vais passer la
parole à à Claude renal président de la
la commission des finances
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
Monsieur le Ministre merci de ces de ces
précision moi je ne suis pas venu dans
cette
réunion avec des idées préconçues ou des
questions préconçu mais je réagis à à à
vos propos parce que il était important
d'avoir un point un peu d'actualité sur
ces sujets dont on sait qu'ils sont h
comment dire ils sont très difficiles
dans leur relations européennes depuis
quelques mois maintenant donc vous nous
marquez quelques évolutions tout en
ayant la prudence de dire que cet accord
euh préalable euh ce compromis entre la
France et l'Allemagne doit encore être
partagé euh et la phrase est courte mais
ce que ça soutend est lourd c'est-à-dire
avoir l'accord des pays frugau de
certains pays qui viennent de d'exercer
des votes très compliqués
euh comment ils vont trouver les les
relations trouver trouver chacun comment
dire un point d'intérêt dans cette
accord on est loin de la coupe aux
lèvres sans doute
euh je voudrais d'abord avoir un point
euh sur finalement l'Allemagne dans
cette présentation apparaît comme ayant
à cœur de trouver une solution avec la
France est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire quel est le point de vue allemand
c'est-à-dire euh pourquoi les Allemands
sont-ils favorables à ce compromis nous
avions eu avec le rapporteur général et
quelques autres une vision de
parlementaire allemands extrêmement quel
que soit d'ailleurs le parti hein euh
extrêmement raide sur cette
question on ne les a pas sentis quand on
les a rencontré à plusieurs reprises
très allant sur les positions françaises
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire donc
d'après vous il il est toujours
important de voir quand il y a un
compromis c'est que tout le monde gagne
quelque chose si je puis dire alors il y
a sans doute quelque chose en relation
avec la situation économique de
l'Allemagne qui est une nouveuté pour
elle et qui peut-être amène à une
facilitation de cet accord mais je vous
laisse vous exprimer sur ce point mais
ça serait intéressant d'avoir un peu
d'après vous votre compréhension de la
position allemande dans dans ce sur ce
sujet deuxème point que nous avions
évoqué lors de la euh du vote ou du non
vote d'ailleurs ce qui nous concernait
sur la loi de programmation des finances
publiques euh est-ce que
c'est ces accords s'ils allaient au bout
sont compatibles avec la loi de
programmation des finances publiqu telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle a été
finalement votée certes au 493 mais voté
euh où faudra-t-il c'est un des points
d'ailleurs que nous avions nous-mêmes
levé dès le départ on avait dit est-ce
que la loi de programmation ne vient pas
un peut tôt c'est-à-dire puisquelle est
votée avant l'accord est-ce que l'accord
modifie d'une certaine façon la
trajectoire des finances publiques que
vous nous proposez euh troè sujet
l'investissement c'est un sujet dont on
avait déjà aussi beaucoup débattu au
Sénat sur la question alors on disait à
l'époque investissement d'avenir on
avait des formules comme ça un peu
vagues un peu général mais finalement là
vous dites bon ok il y a une prise en
compte de l'investissement sur certaines
dans certains objectif de transition de
décarbonation et cetera est-ce que
aujourd'hui on a quelque chose d'un peu
d'un peu clair sur le sujet Quel type
d'investissement peut être pris en
compte je pense que beaucoup d'États se
disent que ça peut être un système
dérogatoire finalement assez lâche
c'est-à-dire qu'on y met dedans beaucoup
d'éléments euh est-ce que est-ce qu'on
va finalement aboutir sur une espèce de
liste enfin liste de principes
évidemment d'investissement qui pourrait
permettre de justifier effectivement
d'avoir euh comment dire dire une une
sortie du déficit de déficit excessif
plus lente que prévu euh voilà voilà les
trois types de questions que j'aurais à
vous poser mais en en réaction immédiate
à vos
propos alors d'abord je partage
évidemment le l'appréciation du
président renal sur le fait que nous ne
sommes pas encore
un accord global il m'a fallu un an de
négociation pour parvenir à un accord
franco-allemand et j'y reviendrai parce
que ça a été de longues négociation je
me suis rendu à de multiples reprises à
Berlin Christian liner s'est rendu à de
multiples reprises à Paris pourquoi
est-ce que nous sommes finalement tombés
d'accord du côté allemand il y a le
souci de parvenir à des règles
crédibles des règles dures mais jamais
appliqué ce ne sont pas des
règles des règles crédibles ce sont des
règles qui sont plus
efficaces du côté français notre ligne
constante a été de préserver les
investissements et la capacité de
réforme puisquells sont au cœur de notre
stratégie de politique économique visant
à avoir plus de croissance et plus
d'emploi et je constate d'ailleurs que
nous avons plus de croissance
aujourd'hui en France que en Allemagne
nous y avons donc gagné cette assurance
là enfin dernier point
peut-être le point qui était le plus au
cœur de la discussion de la nuit
dernière les Allemands n'acceptent de
dérogation à la règle du 0,5 point
d'ajustement structurel par an quand on
est dans le bras
correctif en fonction des
investissements et des réforme de
structure qu'à la condition que cette
dérogation cette flexibilité ne s que en
2025 2026 et
2027 ce qui nous dans le fond nous va
très bien on a pas vocation à rester
structurellement au-dessus des 3 %. mais
ça veut dire pour être tout à fait clair
qu'une fois qu'on est revenu sous les 3
% de déficit en 2027 au plus tard et
bien il faudra y
rester et c'est ça le point le plus
important qui a fait l'objet de 12h de
discussion avec
l'Allemagne dans un cas inverse si cette
règle avait été permanente ça aurait
voulu dire voilà on revient sous les 3
%ant des investissement et des réformes
de structure puis dans le fond on peut
très bien repasser à nouveau sur les 3 %
dans 2 ans ou dans 3 ans puisqu'on a
cette flexibilité permanente la
flexibilité que j'ai obtenu est une
flexibilité transitoire et je pense que
c'est bon pour la France parce que ça va
nous amener à respecter cette obligation
d'être sous les 3 % de déficit il n'y a
pas d'incitation permanente à être
au-dessus des 3 % et à déroger aux
règles donc ça a été cela le point clé
j'ai accepté que ces règles soient
transitoires parce que la France n'a pas
vocation à être en permanence au-dessus
des 3 % et l'Allemagne a accepté de son
côté que pour revenir sous ces 3 % on
tienent compte de notre stratégie
économique d'investissement et de
réforme de structure sur la
compatibilité avec la loi de
programmation des finances publiques la
réponse est oui puisque nous faisons
0,35 points en moyenne d'ajustement
structurel par an mais qu' avec la
souplesse qui nous est donné par les
investissements et les réformes de
structure cela correspond aux 0,5 qui
ont été fixés comme règle c'est
précisément là que la flexibilité nous
sera très utile pour les années 25 26 et
27 enfin sur les investissements ils
sont en lien avec les objectifs
stratégiques fixés par l'Union sur le
climat Fed for55 et le net zerro
investissement Act et également la
défense j'ai beaucoup plaidé sur Cees
sujetsl je pense qu'il faut que nous
fassions très attention c'est vraiment
un des choix structurants pour l'avenir
de l'Europe si nous n'investissons pas
je le vois sur la décarbonation sur les
batteries électriques sur l'hydrogène
vert sur les anodes ou sur les cathodes
sur
l'éolien sur les panneaux Solair sur la
chimie nos industries iront s'installer
aux États-Unis et il y aura pas de
cadeau il n'y aura pas de cadeau donc si
l'Europe n'investit pas massivement dans
l'industrie verte l'industrie verte
s'implantera aux États-Unis avec
l'inflation reduction Act le crédit
d'impôt qui été misise en place et
toutes les facilités qui ont été mise en
place par le gouvernement américain et
nous aurons été responsabl de la
désindustrialisation du continent
européen il y a une nouvelle révolution
industrielle c'est industrie verte la
France a poussé un projet de loi
industrie verte merci du soutien qui m'a
été accordé ici au Sénat nous sommes le
premier état en Europe à avoir mis ce
crédit d'impôt sur l'industrie verte en
place il sera effectif au 1er janvier
nous voulons que la décarbonation soit
une opportunité de réindustrialisation
les États-Unis nont parfaitement compris
la Chine l'a parfaitement compris
l'Europe l'a à moitié compris nous
voudrions qu'elle le comprenne à 100 %
même chose sur les innovations et en
particulier sur l'intelligence
artificielle
si nous ne mettons pas en place les
moyens financiers nous n'y arriverons
pas et je rappelle aussi que sur la
régulation le président de la République
s'est exprimé très clairement hier si
nous avons une régulation qui est plus
stricte que celle des Américains alors
que nous avons moins d'innovation que
les Américains il y a peu de chance que
prospèrent les entreprises
d'intelligence artificielle européenne
c'est pour ça que nous plaidons pour que
les niveaux de régulation mis en place
en Europe ne soit pas plus strict que
ceux qui sont mis en place par
l'exécutive ord
du président Biden enfin un tout dernier
mot sur les investissements ils doivent
pas reposer uniquement sur les États qui
ont les finances publiques qui sont
dégradées un des enjeux clés c'est de
mettre en place l'Union des marchés de
capitaux le financement bancaire sera
insuffisant vous trouverez pas 100
milliards d'euros chez les banques ça ça
n'existe pas surtout dans une période de
taux d'intérêt qui sont beaucoup plus
élevés donc il faut un financement
différent notamment par des fonds
d'investissement aujourd'hui l'Europe
n'a pas d' des marchés de capitaux je
ferai des propositions dès le début de
l'année prochaine pour qu'on reparte sur
des bases qui soient différentes
aujourd'hui dans le fond ça fait 5 ans
qu'on négocie l'Union des marchés de
capitaux sur une base globale qui
suppose une supervision générale et la
fusion de tous les superviseurs
nationaux en un seul superviseur
européen c'est trop ambitieux on y
arrivera pas donc autant prendre une
autre méthode qui est une méthode
d'op-tin où on partirait à deux TR qu
États qui mettraient ensemble leur
supervision et puis ensuite que nous
rejoignent tous ceux qui sont intéressés
par de marché de capitaux et on verra
combien d'états nous rejoignent je pense
qu'il faut être plus pragmatique plus
rapide il y a des besoins de capitaux
qui sont massifs nous ne ferons pasion
des marchés de capitaux en une seule
fois donc autant partir avec une méthode
différente qui est une méthode où se
rassemble tous ceux qui veulent avancer
et puis les autres suivront
ensuite merci monsieur le rapporteur
général puis nous laisserons la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs chrise
ou merci Monsieur le merci Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'entends et j'entends vos
propos votre
volontarisme j'ai envie de dire il il me
réjouit
mais j'ai quand même une question c'est
ce volontarisme les votre
appel comment dirais-je à la
différenciation à la fin d'ailleurs ce
ce qui m'a le plus intéressé c'est votre
propos final parce que sur une union des
marchés de capitaux estce que j'ai beau
je vous écoute et je en même temps j'ai
en tête la situation des finances
publiques de la France qui est
partiement dégradé on est quand même
dans les plus mauvais élèves de la
classe ce qui de l'Union européenne ce
qui moi me pose un problème je reviens
toujours à l'histoire d'une France qui
s'est et d'une Allemagne qui se sont
réconcilié et qui ont posé les deux pays
de l'Europe la Communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier ça me parle un peu
en tant que Lorin et la politique
agricole commune ça me parle beaucoup en
tant que Fils et frères de paysan et je
vois aujourd'hui les dégâts d'un
affaiblissement de ces deux piliers dans
le tandem France-Allemagne mais dans le
concert européen et et donc le le je
dirais les les orientations que vous
proposez j'ai j'ai quand même
aujourd'hui des inquiétudes et je dirais
même des doutes parce que il faut
pouvoir tenir la
voilure
or le niveau
d'investissement nécessaire
ne ne sera possible alors selon qu'il
soit porté par l'Europe faut voir à
quelles conditions mais on a quand même
besoin simultanément parce que je fais
attentionot j'utilise de redresser notre
situation parce que euh au regard des
indicateurs économiques et financiers on
va quand même avoir plus de difficultés
à avoir des conditions de financement de
notre politique d'investissement et
d'innovation ben ell seront moins
favorables que les pays qui sont en
meilleure santé je pense à l'emagne mais
je pense aussi au pays d'ifrugo et ce
qui m'inquiète moi c'est le le tandem
historique le moteur franco-allemand
dont j'ai peur qu'il qu'il
qu'ils connaissent éventuellement des
ratés alors j'entends je sais votre
implication je dirais je la salue hein
dans le la volonté de tenir ce couple
franco-allemand mais je je regarde aussi
les chiffres et puis je regarde la
situation politique dans les deux pays
euh en France ça
devient je dirais
le la force politique de la majorité s'
frrite un peu en Allemagne la coalition
présente des signes de fragilité donc
euh comment dirais-je il faut absolument
qu'on puisse je dirais non seulement euh
reconsolider euh ce couple mais surtout
euh faire en sorte que le noyau dur
autour de ce couple vous l'avez
peut-être un peu esquissé en disant ça
peut être trois quatre pays moi je ne
crois pas euh je ne crois pas du tout
aux forces que j'appellerai
multipolairire c'est souvent des beaux
contextes des voilà des belles
explications c'est des beaux mots et en
général ça se
fracasse sur les premières difficultés
quand elles se présentent voilà donc une
force politique la place de la France et
de l'Allemagne ou d'un d'un noyau plus
dur pour emmener l'Europe sur le chemin
de la réussite parce que vous le savez
comme moi les Français aujourd'hui
doutent et ça me fait plutôt mal de voir
que l'Europe est plutôt
vécu ressentti comme étant à la source
de nos difficultés alors que sans
Europe la France n'a plus la
capacité de donner de battre la mesure
et de donner le tempo voilà donc c'est
c'est plutôt des
des j'ai j'ai besoin de de de comprendre
comment dirais-je le le chemin
réaliste et et je le trouve en tous les
cas je trouve la pente très escarpée
pour arriver à la fois à des endetté
investir au bon niveau et à faire en
sorte que la France retrouve la place
que malheureusement elle a perdu euh que
ce soit dans sa capacité je dirais avoir
les bons indicateurs économiques et
budgétaires mais aussi avoir cette
capacité à
entraîner je partage ce que vient de
dire le rapporteur général en réalité
si on résume les choses à grand trait la
France a plus de dettes mais l'Allemagne
moins de
croissance et l'Allemagne a aussi ses
propres difficultés avec le risque qui
est que l'Allemagne taille dans ses
investissements notamment depuis la
décision de Carl SW je redis à quel
point la situation économique difficile
de
l'Allemagne n'est pas dans l'intérêt du
tout de la France quand l'Allemagne est
en récession l'analyse du FMI c'est que
cela a un impact sur la croissance
française de 0,1 à 0,2 point point de
PIB par an c'est
considérable point de PIB c'est je
rappelle 26 milliards d'euros donc c'est
un impact absolument
considérable deuxème chose je être très
honnête comme toujours on a eu de
longues discussions avec vous avec la
commission des finances sur le sujet
l'histoire de la France c'est l'histoire
d'une l dégradation de ses finances
publiques sur un/art de
siècle un/art de siècle nous sommes en
2023 presque début 2024
en 2000 nous étions à peu près au même
niveau de dette publique que l'Allemagne
% premier choc ça a été celui de la
crise financière ça a été le choc le
plus
massif nous sommes sortis de ce choc
avec 30 points de dette publique de plus
que l'Allemagne l'Allemagne a rétablit
ses comptes et revenu à 60 62 % de dette
publi sur PIB en 2011 là où la France
était au-dessus de 90 %. nous n'avons
jamais rattrapé ces 30
points ensuite de 2011 à 2017 là aussi
les choses se sont lentement dégradé
mais un rythme plus faible pour passé de
90 à 98 % de dett
publique nous sommes revenus en 2018
sous les 3 % nous avons accéléré le
désendettement et ensuite le double choc
le triple des gilets jaunes du covid et
du choc inflationniste nous ont amené à
augmenter la dette publi de 15 points ce
qui est un peu au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne qui est de 12 ou 13 points
mais pas considérablement au-dessus donc
l'histoire sur 25 ans c'est l'histoire
d'e lande dégradation des finances
publiques françaises qui nous ont amené
à réagir en 2017 et en 2018 à amortir
les chocs ensuite mais une fois encore
de manière comparable à celle des autres
États européens et réagir à nouveau
maintenant et je veux le redire avec
beaucoup de force le redressement des
finances publiques est indispensable à
l'indépendance
française indispensable à notre
souveraineté et si certains n'aiment pas
ces grands mots c'est tout simplement
indispensable pour faire face à
n'importe quel nouveau choc conjoncturel
qui pourrait
arver si demain il faut faire face à un
risque militaire encore plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui qu'il faut réinvestir
dans les capacités de défense on fait
comment si on a' pas les réserves
financières
nécessaires si demain il faut faire un
investissement massif de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que nous sommes ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui un des pays
les plus attractifs en Europe nous avons
les scientifiques nous avons les
laboratoires nous avons les algorithmes
et nous avons les super calculateurs
mais qu'on peut pas mettre les 10 ou 15
milliards mais on sacrifie l'avenir des
générations qui viennent des emplois des
emplois qualifiés une capacité de calcul
indépendante
donc cet impératif de redressement des
finances publiques il me tient
extrêmement à cœur parce que c'est notre
intérêt supérieur qui est réellement en
jeu c'est ce que prévoit la de
programmation des finances publiques et
elle doit être tenue coûte que
coûte ce sera pas facile parce
que la croissance économique aujourd'hui
en Europe est faible mais ça reste tout
autant nécessaire et ce n'est pas parce
que la situation que est plus difficile
qu'il ne faut pas tenir rigoureusement
et
scrupuleusement la trajectoire de
rétablissement des finances publiques de
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques alors dans cet environnement
global ce qu'il faut bien comprendre je
pense que vous l'avez tous présent à
l'esprit c'est que nous avons réussi
plus vite que prévu à sortir la crise
inflationniste les chiffres de
l'inflation aujourd'hui baissent
rapidement mais le prix à payer c'est
une croissance un peu plus faible par
que des taux d'intérêt élevé font une
inflation qui baisse mais ça fait aussi
une croissance qui ralentit à partir de
là queles sont nos solutions les seules
solutions c'est soit France 2030 il y a
57 milliards d'euros dessus soit
l'investissement privé mais ça ne peut
pas être de nouveaux investissements
publics ou alors il faut qu'au niveau
européen ça peut être une réflexion
qu'on mène nous disions tous bon écoutez
il y a besoin d'investissement sur la
décarbonation il y a besoin
d'investissement sur l'intelligence
artificielle qu'est-ce que nous faisons
collectivement mais je ne vois pas
d'autres option que cette réflexion
collective sur l'investissement européen
pour gagner en productivité en
croissance et en
emploi merci je passer la la parole à
nos de rapporteurs alors je sais pas
dans quel ordre Florence Christine
Florence allez merci merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
pour ces éclairages donc vous avez avz
aborderé la question du du du calendrier
elle est bien entendu cruciale vous
espérez un un accord d'ici la fin de
l'année s'il devait advenir les
trilogues pourraient nous faire aboutir
à peu près à quelle échéance et si on
nait pas d'accord d'ici la fin de
l'année est-ce qu'on
imagine une mise en heure enfin en tout
cas un accord final avant les élections
européennes bon sachant quand même les
risques que l'on a sur ces échéances euh
est-ce que ce risque làà peut pousser
les pays à un accord à une volonté
d'aboutir avant ses échéances et euh
même dans sa dans dans cette perspective
l'année
2024 serait une année de transition et
peut-être même l'année 2025 ENF en tout
cas c'est ce qui a ressorti nos échanges
avec la Commission européenne donc sur
cette année de transition
2024 la France sera euh en déficit
excessif est-ce qu'une procédure pour
déficit excessif pourrait être engagée
puisque la réforme ne serait pas encore
complètement adopté c'est une question
que nous nous
posions ensuite bon je partage tout à
fait votre votre avis concernant les
besoins d'investissement et vraiment je
m'interroge parce que on a vu au fil des
négociation l'introduction de clauses de
sauvegarde et donc de critères quand
même relativement uniforme alors que
l'esprit de la réforme l'esprit de la
commission c'était davantage de
différenciation et finalement depuis 40
ans on a accumulé des déficits et alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a des défis immenses
qu'on a les États-Unis qui sont très
réactifs et vous l'avez très bien
souligné dont la productivité augmente
est-ce que finalement ce que vous avez
abordé en fin de propos est-ce qu'on
devra pas au niveau européen
s'interroger sur ce que nous faisons
collectivement face à B au niveau
d'endettement de certains pays dont la
France que nous connaissons mais pour
voilà faire face à la rivalité
extraeuropéenne et aux enjeux qui sont
essentiels de transition écologique je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
alors
euh juste une question un peu peut-être
provocatrice parce que vous nous avez
présenté la réforme telle qu'elle est
envisag
et donc finalement est-ce qu'on a pas
déjà finalement des règles qui vont être
très complexes avec les nombreuses
dérogation que vous avez évoqué par
ailleurs finalement est-ce qu'on va pas
aussi retrouver un autre défaut des
règles anciennes à savoir la
proclicité alors que c'était quelque
chose dont on voulait se se séparer
après une autre j'ai dit quoi
oui toute compris euh ensuite une
seconde réforme en fait une seconde
question qui porte sur le le sujet du
contrôle
démocratique notamment parce que les
plans nationaux vont pouvoir aller
jusqu'à un horizon temporel de 17 ans
donc c'est déjà bien au-delà des mandats
des des des des parlementaires dans les
pays de l'Union européenne c'est bien
au-delà des mandats des différents
gouvernements donc dans quelle mesure
une nouvelle majorité qui arriverait au
pouvoir pourrait remettre en cause ce
qu'a décidé la majorité précédente
puisque de ce qu'on comprend notamment
de ce que la Commission a avait fait
comme ouverture dans sa proposition
d'avril 2023 les choses étaient vraiment
très très très très limité et enfin euh
quel sera le rôle des parlements
nationaux
euh dans le dans ce cadre là est-ce
qu'ils auront un rôle à jouer notamment
sur le respect des états membr vis-à-vis
de leurs engagements européens parce qu'
en fait ils sont quasiment jamais
mentionnés dans les documents qui
circule jusqu'à
présent sur le calendrier donc de deux
choses l'une soit il y a un accord d'ici
la fin décembre soit il n'y a pas
d'accord
je veux être très clair s'il y a pas
d'accord d'ici fin défembre il n'y aura
pas d'accord du tout je ne pense pas que
nous puissions repartir après une
année de négociation qui ont été longues
difficiles avec une nouvelle présidence
sur de nouvelles négociations donc nous
devons conclure fin 2023 comme je l'ai
toujours indiqué et je pense que l'état
d'esprit de compromis dont tu as fait
preuve l'Allemagne l' Italie l'Espagne
la France devrait inspirer l'ensemble
des autres États-membres faute de quoi
nous reviendrions aux anciennes règles
elles sont inapplicables et elles
marqueraient une faiblesse politique
européenne s'il y a un accord c'est
pourquoi je vais continuer à me battre
tous les jours en appelant régulièrement
mes homologues le trilogue devrait avoir
lieu en février au plus tard l'année
2024 serait une période de transition et
les nouvelles règles s'appliqueraient en
2025 s'agissant procédure pour déficit
excessif elle sera décidée au printemps
prochain il est hautement probable qu'au
printemps 2024 la France comme une
dizaine d'autres États européens sera en
procédure pour déficit excessif nous
sommes au-dessus des 3 % c'est une
surprise pour personne et tant que nous
ne sommes pas sous les 3 % nous sommes
dans cette procédure d'où l'importance
qu'il y a à conserver une marge de
manœuvre pour les investissements et
pour les réformes enfin je rejoins
totalement ce que vous avez dit
sur les bons choix pour
l'Europe les règles du PACT de stabilité
de croissance sont importantes pour
fixer un cadre collectif mais ce qui se
joue pour l'avenir européen c'est notre
capacité à retrouver de la
productivité sans
productivité ce sera un appauvrissement
collectif de l'Europe et la productivité
elle dépend de facteurs parfaitement
identifiés la formation la qualification
laag des salariés tout au long de leur
vie et l'investissement dans
l'innovation dans les technologies de
rupture et en particulier dans
l'intelligence artificielle et là il y a
vraiment un choix stratégique à faire
certains pays d'Asie ont déjà fait une
croix surintelligence artificielle
indépendante mais utilise massivement
l'intelligence artificielle importé des
États-Unis c'est le cas de beaucoup de
pays asiatiques c'est le cas par exemple
de Singapour et ces états vont avoir des
gains de productivité considérables dans
les années à venir si nous européens
nous n'investissons pas non seulement
sur l'application actuelle de l'IA mais
sur notre propre Ia nous serons laisser
sur le côté et nous perdrons la course
par rapport aux États-Unis au pays
asiatiques à la Chine et à tous les pays
développés donc il faut faire très
attention parce que il y a deux Europes
qui peuvent se profiler à échéance de 25
ou 30 ans une Europe qui se replie sur
elle-même vieillissante
qui perd la productivité et qui
s'appauvrit collectivement et une Europe
qui fait le choix résolu des nouvelles
technologies de l'investissement de la
productivité de la formation et qui
reste une des grandes puissances
économiques de la planète donc faisons
attention à ne pas confondre la fin et
les moyens le PACT de stabilité est le
moyen de garantir la stabilité
financière de l'Europe ce n'est pas une
fin en soi et je me suis tué expliquer
cela à tous les autres États européens
matin midi et soir à l'occasion de
toutes les réunions une fois encore très
constructive que nous avons eu depuis
maintenant 6 mois le PACT de stabilité
est une nécessité il est un moyen pour
éviter tout dérapage il n'est pas une
fin en soi il doit être au service d'un
objectif politique celui d'une Europe
prospère sûr et
décarboné Christina Vard est-ce que les
règles sont trop complexes je pense
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus simples que
les règles existantes beaucoup plus
simple que cette règle du 120e qui était
incompréhensible pour tout le monde
est-ce qu'il y a un risque de procyclité
c'est évidemment un des risques majeurs
parfaitement identifié que vous avez
raison de souligner parce que rien ne
serait pire que des règles budgétaires
qui enfonceraient l'Europe dans la
croissance mol voire dans la récession
je pense qu'il y a trois éléments qui
permettent de garantir que ce risque là
est
écarté le premier élément c'est que ces
règles sont appliquées sur du moyen
terme et qu'il y a une possibilité
d'étendre de 4 à 7 ans les périodes
d'ajustement en fonction de
l'investissement et des réformes de
structure c'est une fois encore l'apport
français je pense que c'est un apport
extrêmement important qui était très
difficile à négocier l'Allemagne partait
sur du 4 + 2 ans maximum voire sur qu
sec nous avons obtenu 4 + 3 ce qui est
une vraie incitation à éviter le
caractère procyclique des mesures et
investir et à faire des réformes de
structure la deuxième chose c'est que
les références quantitatives ne sont que
des gardes-fous ce ne sont pas des
obligations en tant que tell je pense
que ça permet de garder une marge de
manœuvre enfin le troisème élément c'est
la révision tous les 6 mois des
sanctions qui s'applique à des états qui
ne respecteraient pas les règles ce qui
permet aussi de garantir que si elles
ont un caractère procyclique on peut
modifier ses sanctions enfin sur le
Parlement il devrait naturellement être
consulté dès lors qu'il s'agit de règles
qui s'applique au budget français
oui audreé audre
linconel merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Ministre euh j'ai
peut-être posé une question un peu moins
consensuelle ce qui ne veut pas dire que
je n'adère pasombre de propos qui ont
été tenus avant moi en partie les vôtres
ou encore les questions de de Claude
renal ou de Florence platrix néanmoins
il y a 5000 personnes qui ont marché
contre l'austérité à Bruxelles notamment
à la à l'appel des des organisations
syndicales d'un nombre de pays et ces
personnes ont marché parce qu'elle
craignent justement contrairement à ce
que vous avez essayé de nous expliquer
que le retour du pacte de stabilité de
croissance se traduisent précisément par
l'austérité que vous-même vous nous
dites souhaiter éviter ces organisations
demandent une une flexibilité dans dans
les critères et notamment l'intégration
des de de des investissements liés à la
neutralité carbone vous avez essayé de
nous expliquer en quoi cette flexibilité
existait en quoi cette intégration des
des investissements en faveur de la
croissance verte existait mais vous avez
aussi dit et c'est là où je vais poser
ma question vous avez aussi dit que la
souplesse dans les mécanismes
d'ajustement était lié
aux investissements qui seraient fait ou
aux réformes de structure vous avez
insisté plusieurs fois sur le fait que
c'était les investissements et les
réformes de structure et vous avez cité
dans les réformes de structure les
exemples de la réforme des retraites et
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage et
vous savez que sur cette question là
autant je pense qu'il y a probablement
unanimité ici sur le soutien aux
investissements en général et aux
investissements de décarbonation et
d'innovation en particulier autant sur
ces réformes de structure et sur ces
réformes des retraites et du chômage il
n'y a pas unanimité ni ici ni ailleurs
est-ce que vous avez une idée dans les
négociations que vous avez pu mener
notamment avec le noyau deur des pays
mais aussi avec les les 23 autres
États-membres qui restent à convaincre
de la part que prendrai les réformes de
structure versus l'investissement parce
que c'est cela aussi qui fera que vous
serez ou non convaincant vis-à-vis de
ces 5000 personnes qui aujourd'hui
marchent et qui ont encore peur malgré
le discours rurant que vous nous tenez
ICI que ça se traduise par de
l'austérité
merci alors moi je je veux rassurer ceux
qui ont défilé j'espère qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de Français par milieux parce
que je pense qu'avec 4,9 % de déficit
public et 56 % de dépenses publiques
dans notre richesse nationale nous
sommes face à une austérité généreuse
euh en tout cas je vraiment dire des
choses avec franchise que c'est
l'intérêt de
ces échanges devant la commission des
affaires européennes moi je ne veux pas
que la France se singularise par un
niveau de déficit et de dettte plus
élevé que ses partenaires or c'est le
cas aujourd'hui et ça ne me satisfait
pas et je souhaite que nous revenions
dans la norme européenne parce que c'est
bon pour l'intérêt national et ça permet
de garantir notre ancrage européen ça a
été par un certain nombre d'entre vous
ici nous avons un niveau de dette
publique un niveau de déficit qui
aujourd'hui doivent être réduits
rapidement pour revenir dans
l'étiage européen et sur les réformes de
structure c'est sans doute un point sur
lequel nous aurons des desés acccords je
me suis exprimé là-dessus je pense que
nous avons beaucoup de réformes de
structure qui restent indispensable
devant nous nous avons fait la réforme
des retraites je pense qu'il faut une
réforme de structure du lycée
professionnel je pense qu'il faut une
réforme de structure pour mieux
accompagner les jeune dans l'emploi je
me suis exprimé sur l'assurance chômage
et ne retire pas un mot de ce que j'ai
dit je pense qu'on ne rend pas service à
nos aînés dont je fais partie
aujourd'hui en leur disant qu'ils
peuvent rester 27 mois indemnisé au
chômage alors que leur intérêt au
contraire de reprendre l'activité le
plus vite possible parce qu'on sait que
plus on estâé dans sa carère
professionnel plus les risques de ne pas
retrouver un emploi augmente au fur à
mesure qu'on reste au chômage j'ai fait
des propositions sur des contrats à 80 %
de temps d'activité 90 % de rémunération
100% de cotisation retraite qui à mon
avis doivent permettre de maintenir les
personnes de plus de 55 ans dans
l'emploi augmenter le doactivité des
personnes de plus de 55 ans ça reste à
mes yeux totalement
indispensable et c'est pas une question
d'austérité nous devons augmenter le
volume global de travail de la France
faute de quoi nous ne pourrons pas
financer notre modèle social et ça n'a
dans le fond pas grand-chose à voir avec
les les règles européennes mais je veux
rassurer il est pas question d'avoir de
l'austérité l'intérêt de ces réformes de
structure c'est qu'elles augmentent le
taux d'emploi elles augmentent la
croissance et donc elles réduisent
d'autant l'effort nécessaire sur la
réduction des dépenses publiques nous
n'avons AC le président de la République
jamais présenter une copie qui reposait
exclusivement sur la réduction des
dépenses publiques nous avons toujours
présenté une copie où il y a un
équilibre entre réduction des dépenses
publiques et soutien à la croissance à
l'emploi et au taux d'activité des
Français alors après juste pour pour
élargir effectivement sur la question de
de
l'austérité là où nous pouvons avoir un
différent avec un certain nombre d'État
je le redis c'est sur la vision globale
que nous avons de l'Europe à la fin je
je l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises deant
mes homologues européens je le redis
devant les sénatrices et les sénateurs
la bonne tenue des comptes publicques
n'est pas une fin en soi c'est un moyen
pour garantir la prospérité et les
investissements et là-dessus il y a les
différents sensibilités culturelles qui
je crois n'ont échappé à
personne merci Monsieur le Ministre
juste une petite question Stéphane
sotarel pour la commission des finances
parce que je pense que le ministre était
sur un temps limité avec nous si si si
c'est possible voulais juste revenir
monsieur le ministre sur des points que
vous avez déjà évoqué mais pour
peut-être les éclairer encore davantage
la question de ce qui pourrait être
financé par le budget européen pour
soulager l'effort d'investissement qui
relève des
états on l'a connu pendant pendant la
crise récemment est-ce que c'est une
perspective et qui renvoie à la
négociation sur le budget européen
lui-même est-ce que on a une
prévisibilité sur ce point-là deuxème
question sur la productivité vous l'avez
vous avez beaucoup insisté c'est un un
sujet majeur euh qui renvoie peut-être
aussi à la notion d'investissement parce
que dans la productivité il y a beaucoup
d'éléments qui dépendent de de la
formation et et et et donc quelle notion
de dépensees d'investissement on peut
avoir est-ce que les les notions de
dépenses d'investissement qu'on a
jusqu'àors sont encore les bonnes au
regard de ses besoins notamment sur
l'amélioration de la productivité et ma
troisième question ou remarque rejoind
la question de la productivité c'est
celle de la démographie la démographie
de l'Europe qui peut-être aussi explique
la position de l'Allemagne avec les
écarts de démographie que l'on connaît
mais où la France est aujourd'hui sur un
retournement démographique voilà donc
sur ces trois points est-ce que vous
avez des éléments complémentaires
éventuellement d'éclairage
merci alors la démographie je vais
terminer par le commencer par le dernier
point c'est évidemment un enjeu
clé de soutenabilité de la dette et de
soutenabilité du modèle social quand
notre modèle social a été créé au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
il y avait peu de prestation et beaucoup
de
cotisants 70 ans plus tard il y a
beaucoup de prestations et de moins en
moins de cotisants donc forcément ça
cause une énorme difficulté sommes pas
le seul État dans cette situation l'un
des États qui va être confronté à
changement démographique le plus brutal
c'est la Chine mais vous verrez que
l'ajustement chinois notamment sur la
question immobilière rque d'être très
brutal à cause justement de cette
démographie après comment est-ce qu'on
peut financer on peut augmenter
effectivement le budget européen mais je
pense que les marges de manœuvres sont
quand même assez réduites parce que je
rappelle que nous y contribuons à
hauteur de 17,4 %. euh il y a des
possibilités aussi avec la dette je
rappelle que la dette européenne et
l'émissions de dette en commun nous ont
fortement protégé pendant la crise du
covid et à tous ceux qui ne croient pas
dans l'Europe s'il n'y avait pas eu la
zone euro la monnaie commune et l'Europe
pendant la crise du covid je pense que
nous aurions vécu un une vague de
licenciement et de faillite comme la
France on a jamais connu depuis 1945
mais l'émission de dette en commun nous
a permis de nous protéger parce que
c'est une option pour la suite je pense
que ça mérite discussion mais en tout
état de cause aujourd'hui il faut
d'abord définir les règles regarder
queles sont les besoins d'investissement
étudier la possibilité de la mise en
place rapide d'union des marchés de
capitaux y compris dans un nombre limité
d'État et après regarder les autres
options qui s'offrent à nous merci
Monsieur le Ministre assci près que la
dette européenne si si elle est de
nouveau contractée elle doit aussi
s'appuyer sur des ressources propres
parce que c'est pas c'est quand même pas
les États qui vont finalement
externaliser leur dettes à l'Union
européenne en ayant des contributions
qui augmentent on sait très bien Claude
renal pour terminer
oui merci monsieur le Président juste
quelques quelqu mot pour revenir un peu
à l'exposé de de base puisque c'est
quand même ça l'accord pour l'instant
franco-allemand et je voulais vous
interroger pour savoir finalement au
bout de 13 ans c'est-à-dire 3 ans pour
sortir de la procédure de déficit
excessif ça comme ça 10
ans finalement pour un principe de dette
avec la possibilité d'avoir un point de
dette à moins moyenne ça veut dire que
vous stabiliser la dette de la France
dans 13 ans autour de 90 % c'est un peu
l'objectif que vous donnez euh pour que
ce pour que pour bien calibrer le le le
sujet hein c'est c'est un petit peu ça
et et et est-ce que ça c'est euh c'est
votre c'est votre vision de la
diminution de la dette euh à moyen terme
où est-ce que vous vous comment dire
vous donner un objectif un peu plus
ambitieux si je puis dire de diminution
de la dette ou est-ce que c'est pas
nécessaire ou est-ce que autrement dit
est-ce que finalement les 60 % sont
remplacés par les 90 % je je je fais
simple
quoi c'est c'est un peu à la grosse ma
question j'en ai conscience mais
l'intérêt pour vous c'est de permettre
de
d'affiner c'est c'est difficile à dire à
10 ans parce qu'en
réalité le point clé ce sera notre
capacité à augmenter la productivité et
le niveau de croissance français après
le désendettement il va très rapidement
dès lors qu'on a plus de productivité et
plus de
croissance le désendettement n'est pas
rapide lorsqu'il ne repose que sur la
réduction des dépenses simplement des
dépenses qui sont
incompressibles sauf à remettre en cause
les grands équilibres du modèle français
on peut renoncer à l'arme nucléaire on
peut renoncer être une grande nation de
défense dans ce caslà c'est plus la
France on peut renoncer à avoir des
services publics hospitaliers de grande
qualité mais c'est plus la France donc
on va très vite toucher les limites sur
la réduction des dépenses je suis tout à
fait engagé dans cette réduction mais
c'est pas ça qui permettra de passer
d'un dette de 110 % à une dette de 50 %
ce qui permet réellement de baisser
rapidement la dette c'est l'augmentation
de la productivité et de la croissance
et là si vous augmentez fortement le
numérateur effectivement ça va très
vite
bien merci monsieur le ministre de nous
avoir éclairé sur les positions de la
France voilà maintenant le Parlement
dans une chapelle monastique maintenant
le le
Parlement est aussi là pour travailler
quelquefois au côté du gouvernement et
je pense qu'en en ces temps difficiles
peut-être qu'il sera important qu'on
puisse porter en tout cas la voix du
Sénat sur sur cette question du du PCT
de stabilité sous une forme ou sous une
autre afin de afin de de renforcer la
position la position française puis vous
dire aussi que dans notre commission des
affaires européennes on commence à
s'intéresser fortement au budget
européen parce que il il il nous
inquiète de plus en plus euh c'est
toujours plus de de contribution fortte
sur des programmes qui étaient
inattendus je comprends la guerre en
ucraine la crise du covid mais mais on
commence à à entendre parler de chiffres
astronomiques et surtout
de potentiel coupe dans le cadre
financier pluriannuel et sur des postes
franchement qui seraient qui seraiit
pour la France très très délétaire je
pense en particulier à l'agriculture je
pense à la recherche euh où où nous
avons nous une certaine une certaine
voix à exprimer une certaine force à
confirmer